porca una volta morirò così tutti
ragazzi venuti questo video sono fra vj
sto facendo questa intro orlando e stone
tipo le 7 del mattino in america quindi
adesso mi entra qualcuno in camera mi
uccida è un sito della sua completa di
carla tra hold'em e quindi oggi siamo
soggetti
altro tema non avreste mai detto io da
ragazzi un gioco su un gatto molto figo
tipo questo sì questo è un gatto ragazzi
lo so che è un po diverso però bisogna
rispettare tutti quanti gli animali
quindi anche lui non è diverso la
sentite non guardatelo così perché mio
dio lui non è diverso da nessun altro
che è in bisogna rispettare yen vi
lascio gioco ragazzi buona visione
nonché ragazzi è una roba tipo è un
tutorial debuttato le cose fatte sono
già accaduto perfetto non so neanche
fare le cose basilari ma non l'ho
buttato giù vago ha giù proprio e vabbè
mica che pignoli regala quattro su dieci
questo è il tutorial ragazzi voglio
vedere se non riesco a fare il tutorial
cos'altro dovrei riuscire a fare una
cosa impossibile perfetto jump in the
box su continuous sono un fenomeno al
gatto in un'altra vita sono convinto
perché guarda che roba c'è max gallob
lawson mi ha voluto si perfetto continui
andiamo avanti lei proprio non fare robe
che hai con te disi youmans eni morta in
to make a mess
non posso sopportare questi esseri umani
ancora per molto facciamo un disastro
distruggi 340 ma che cazzo sono gatti
nator ragazzina roba sono accaduto devo
fare ma posso grattare sta roba no vabbè
seriamente
vabbè ma che idiozia e yacht grade
jumping craze che figo c'è posso santa
no vabbè ma che figo ci sono anche gli
upgrade ragazzi l'hanno migliorato 2
miliardi di volte sto gioco
non ho idea di che cosa mi abbia fatto
il mio padrone ma così tanto per
chiarire uno stronzo perché saranno
sarei così incazzato quindi se sono così
incazzato perché uno stronzo ragazzi in
questo momento per chiunque di voi ha un
gatto in casa in questo momento io sto
comandando esattamente lui quindi se voi
tornati in salotto è un disastro
ed è colpa mia sappiatelo più foto
unlocked chi è questo boudrìe mi
cacciano dei nomi che sono tipo quelli
di skyrim sfigati e sono del cazzo di
gatti evento cos'è sta roba
la povera pesa pierce dove noi ma
veramente l'hanno migliorata così tanto
c'è ma che figo hanno fatto apparire le
cose in mezzo alle stanze bellissimo
cos'è cibo per gatti sfidi la madonna
sono entrato barrichello
belle le zie mica salto aumentato
velocità aumentata e cazzo sono superman
mi metto a volare sono a posto ci
arriverò mai lazio nella vita che
scopriremo insieme verso l'infinito e
non ce lo fa si fa ma serio come cazzo
fatto regali vari impossibile ragazzino
non chiedetevi come ho fatto non lo so
neanche io sto facendo dei bordelli
allucinanti lega sono orgoglioso di me
stesso
posso fare così anche a casa mia con mia
mamma mi picchiano mia mamma mi picchia
probabilmente ma ci provo lo stesso la
prossima volta vai così che poi razzista
musicale orecchiabilissima c'è mentre
accesso cazzo di gioco certa musica che
mi sta martellando i team plan
[Musica]
in tutto questo buttato giù solo
deodorante per fare comunque ragazzi a
parte sta sta roba
non sono neanche a metà e sta finendo il
tempo quindi sono un genio devo essere
un master accusa la carta ragazzi ma che
il gatto avete trovato che gli usa la
carta igienica pure dopo che ha finto di
cagare cioè ma la meraviglia proprio al
grade lo sblocco gli upgrade con la
carta igienica giusto swat in chrysler
ciò vuol dire che sta arrivando la slot
a che bello i vasi vasi della mamma ciao
mamma ebe i vasi che avevi una volta
bellissimo cioè l'upgrade mi chiamo ho
perso l'upgrade ragazzi la l'occasione
della mia vita andate in fumo non si
possono perdere queste occasioni della
vita cioè non sa die gatto mio come ti
permetti di belle cose ascolta e va beh
va beh ragazzi diamo diamo delle
medaglie sfigati ma guarda lì che
collare che è bellissimo e se veramente
figo jackie fatelo dire una volta
c'erano giochi tipo metal gear
battlefield metal slug poi hanno oggi
c'è cat la tela dei major ragazzi che
vale lo stesso il super nintendo tutto
giù tutto giovani e il televisore ma sì
ma [ __ ] tanto il mio padrone
stupido chi se ne frega ragazzi ce la
posso ancora fare io credimi non mollerò
fino alla fine fino alla fine fino alla
fine e me ne mancano 100 ma chi se ne
frega io non mollo
kat no non mi mettete stans vi prego i
piatti 8 giu cazzo non vincerò mai ma
che a dieci secondi va 23 che io ci ho
provato come se fosse l'ultima cosa che
potessi fare nella mia vita sono
orgoglioso
me ne frega un cazzo sono orgoglioso di
me stesso ma posso sbloccarmi ma vero
va bene fatemi usare lui vi prego uil la
mia cena cinque minuti in ritardo
facciamo un casino ma ovvio se per caso
viario
la scena cinque minuti di ritardo siete
autorizzati a forza cagata due tessere
dei gatti ovviamente sono non funzionano
mi sento più forte essendo un gatto
giallo non so perché i gatti gialli mi
esprimono potenza dai che ti regalo
non lo so that he porta a mangiare il
sushi se ce la fai carone poi chiama uil
dai uil forza 66 da mia nonna li butta
giù meglio ai perfetto perfetto di
quella ma c'è una sedia ok bravo era
difficile poi fa dai tutti i porno giù
per terra bravissimo che il tuo padrone
sarà contentissimo di questa cosa ne
manchi al 100 regalo quattro minuti ce
la posso fare forza butta su tutto il
telecomando dire poi chiuderò il video
con quello sono convinto ragazzi non vi
sembra il libro più bello che abbiate
mai visto è libero e avrà me guarda
merita una stretta di mano cazzo e vabbè
voluto stringergli la mano più o meno
questo devo prendere il calzino
cos'è una luce ma cove ma non serve un
cazzo la luce dai una seria o guadagno
dei punti prendendo la mi sto prendendo
per il culo non fermi un attimo che se
non l'ho presa perfetto mica pensavo mi
stesse prendendo solo per il culo
sarebbe stato tragico ragazzi perché la
luce funziona sia sui gatti che su
famiglia
mancano dieci non rompe le balle se ce
l'ha fatta è stata la cosa più difficile
della mia vita naba [ __ ] sono sudato
marzo con ragazzi a parte sta la voglio
io sta camera ma immediatamente cioè di
chi è che si permette di avere una
stanza così bella ma [ __ ] faccio
questo regali smetto perché veramente
buttare cose non è il mio hobby
preferiti c'è un alce io ero nasce una
volta la madonna che granocchia ragazze
guarda guarda ti che fissa le parti è
partita una disco a caso che bella
gnocca vuoi ballare con me se e allora
dammi la mano che facciamo un bar
no no no non così eh va beh non so
ballare non so bra e succede non sia
scusami non vuole giuro che non volevo
se ci fosse anche è la madonna che cazzo
di palaradi skull comprato cioè mio dio
si vede anche in giardino è bellissima
avete la casa così a checa spento ma che
cazzo fate ma [ __ ] che è bravo la
coca tutta giusto taggio bravi così
festa festa dai che tua moglie [ __ ]
forza ma chi è che ti preciso deve
pulire queste cagate che faccio queste
ragazze la motivazione del perché non ho
un gatto 6 star o mio dio ho trovato un
ananas gangster ragazzi
[Musica]
roba va beh ma la samp e non voglio
chiedere non voglio fare domanda anche i
fiori perfetto le viole so viola le rose
sono marrani e ci hai rotto i [ __ ] e
non era tipo che è successo si è spenta
la musica ragazzo è successo ma dove chi
è che ha spento ragazzi uno paga il
biglietto per la discoteca entra entra e
non c'è musica ma che ca o ma come
stiamo
via stronzi o perfetto c'è una roba ma
che come si permettono questi plore dei
di spegnere la musica la mia musica
bellissima avevo mancato quarti scaffali
perfetto vaia che ce la faccia dai che
ce la faccio
ne manca un pò chi va che manca al 20
bravo di salto migliore della vita zio
dai dai che sei questa gatto landi a
gatto landia è infatti ho vinto ho vinto
fatemi capire cos'è suo think ma cos'è
sto swat
non ho capito entra vista cagata perché
mia amen
allora ragazzi forse l'ultimo perché sta
diventato ormai sono diventato maestro
nel disintegrare camere però è una cosa
che sapevo fare benissimo
già da piccolo quindi non ce n'era
bisogno fermi fermi fermi tutti zitti
zitti non voglio neanche la musica zitti
tutti chi cazzo è che si mette sti
calzini e illegale arrestate queste
persone e neanche la befana metterebbe
qualcosa dentro si cazzo di calze
indicus questo come la mangiare pure io
non so perché ma è appetibile è una roba
tipo forse va beh sono invitato
potentissimo mai così ragazzi altro che
braccio di ferro gli spinaci o sosta
cosa ha dato già vinto teigen tipo
durato un minuto sto livello favo così
come superman ma che roba
bravissima mica è un fenomeno studiato
mani mimì vola non è un gatto e un super
guard è un super mica è una roba mi dà
soddisfazione sto gioco è bellissimo ma
so perché mi mimì veramente mi sfogano
sono incazzato adesso infatti giocano a
calata dal the magic gioca su ca e no
kat farne uno per uno la più divertente
da vedere meglio così dal corno ragazzo
che no no ho detto che quel cazzo di
calzino te lo devi prendere infilare su
per il culo anche ragazzi concluso che
l'episodio però gli piace che mettete un
oggetto in meno sulla credenza di casa
vostra
perché in fondo lo so che vi piace far
casino con l'assenza seguito è piaciuta
sato momento mi piace anche la pace di
facebook e come livido a trattare
siziano so se il city siete civili non
posso no ma stavo scherza eh perché devo
buttare giù le cose o dei disagi segreti
di sky tree ci dividiamo in un prossimo
vinto della ragazza